let's talk about the foods that can potentially
boost libido both in men and women so we're
talking about foods that have an aphrodisiac
effect so i first want to tell you if you're not
sleeping if you have too much chronic stress
if you consume a high carb high sugar diet
then none of these are going to work
because these will very easily nullify
libido so testosterone is the hormone that tends
to increase the libido in both men and women
but of course with women they don't need much
because if they have too much testosterone or
other androgens what's going to happen is they're
going to get facial hair and they're going to get
a deeper voice and they'll lose their hair on the
top of their head and a lot of other issues so
we're just talking about the right balance
now anything that increases estrogen too much
will lower testosterone and lower
libido and that would be alcohol dairy
too much dairy could potentially give you too much
estrogen and of course soy soy oil soy protein
isolates can lower testosterone and then tap
water um make sure you get a filter there are
all sorts of chemicals and hormones in tap water
including estrogen so that can be a big problem
all right so let's say these are handled right
here okay pistachios pistachios are high in this
amino acid called arginine which increases nitric
oxide which guess how viagra works by increasing
nitric oxide and so pistachios can help to a
certain degree and also selenium can increase
not just fertility but can actually help healthy
testosterone levels all right number two oysters
why because out of all the foods out there oysters
have the most zinc and zinc is one of the most
powerful minerals to increase testosterone levels
also oysters have copper which also can help
testosterone levels as well as selenium all right
number three coffee coffee will do two things if
you have too much that can lower testosterone
if you have just a little bit that can help
the caffeine and the polyphenols will help
support healthy testosterone levels and then
we get this herb called saffron it's very very
expensive but they even use it to treat depression
it can increase your mood and it can increase
fertility and then we have number five maca root
they call it the peruvian viagra it can increase
testosterone number six asparagus in asparagus
you have this natural steroid building block that
can actually help you increase your testosterone
levels of course we're not talking about you
know the steroids that someone would inject
themselves with as a bodybuilder all right next
one truffles so truffles are a type of mushroom
there's been some interesting studies that it can
increase testosterone all right number eight beets
can increase nitric oxide like pistachios now if
you're on keto make sure you don't do too many
beets because they are a bit higher in sugar
but a small amount is going to be totally fine
but again none of these are going to create any
effect unless you're sleeping keep your stress
down and you're on a low carb diet and of course
exercise also will help too all right thanks for
watching hey before you go real quick i have a
course entitled how to bulletproof your immune
system it's a free course i want you to take it
and here's why here's you here is your environment
everyone is focused on this over here
avoiding your environment but what about here
what about strengthening your immune system
that's what's missing this course will show
you how to bulletproof yourself and so you can
tolerate and resist your environment much better
by strengthening your own immune system i put
a link down in the description right down below
check it out and get signed up today